- Régine Laurent, président de
cette commission spéciale sur
les droits des enfants de la
protection de la jeunesse.
Bonsoir, madame Laurent.
- Bonsoir Monsieur Roy.
- Alors, si j'avais une baguette
magique et que je disais oui
à toutes vos recommandations,
on va en parler après en détail,
beaucoup plus de prévention,
une DPJ plus efficace avec plus
de moyens pour les intervenants,
est-ce que le genre de cas
horrible de Granby il y a
deux ans aurait été évité?
- Ça veut dire beaucoup
de choses. Ça veut dire qu'on
serait déjà installé avec
votre baguette magique dans
une société bienveillante
où tout le monde collectivement,
on prend soin de nos enfants,
qu'on fait de la prévention.
Ce que ça veut dire aussi, c'est
qu'on respecte les droits
des enfants. Et c'est de là la
charte des droits des enfants.
Ça veut dire qu'en ce moment,
il y a des délais prévus dans
la loi qui doivent être
respectés pour stabiliser
l'enfant, instaurer une
permanence dans sa vie, empêcher
les problèmes d'attachement,
empêcher les enfants de
développer des comportements
qui ne sont pas corrects
et qu'on est obligé souvent
de médicaliser, etc.
Donc, ce que ça voudrait dire,
c'est qu'on décide de prendre
soin de nos enfants et on décide
aussi d'accompagner les familles
qui peuvent vivre
des difficultés.
- Donc, on évite des drames
comme celui de Granby,
en principe.
- Oui, voilà. Et on évite
surtout 118 000 signalements
dans la vaste majorité ne sont
pas reconnus. Ça veut dire
qu'on va prendre soin de ces
enfants et de ces familles
pour qui quelqu'un a levé
le drapeau rouge.
- Vous mettez... Il y a beaucoup
de recommandations qui
s'adressent en amont du
problème, avant que ça arrive
à la DPJ. Vous dites : en fait,
plus on va travailler en amont,
moins il y aura de cas lourds
à la DPJ, mieux on va se porter.
Mais votre prévention dont vous
parlez, à l'école, les CLSC,
les milieux communautaires,
avez-vous chiffré? Parce que
ce que vous demandez, c'est
qu'il y ait un guichet unique,
qu'il y ait plus
de psychologues, plus d'aide
à l'école, qu'on décèle...
qu'une famille qui a des
problèmes puisse appeler le CLSC
et avoir un rendez-vous genre
dans deux semaines, pas dans
trois ans. Ça, ça coûte...
Avez-vous mis un chiffre
là-dessus.
- Je laisse avec plaisir
le gouvernement chiffrer. Mais
prenons les choses autrement.
Est-ce qu'on croit vraiment
qu'au Québec, on a les moyens
de regarder la maltraitance des
enfants? Est-ce qu'on a encore
les moyens au Québec de ne pas
prendre soin des familles?
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
pour la société? Ça veut dire
des enfants qui vont avoir
des problèmes de comportement,
qui vont avoir des difficultés
à l'école, des familles qui sont
pas prises en charge, donc ça va
se détériorer pour se retrouver,
ces enfants-là, aux soins
intensifs, que c'est la DPJ.
Est-ce qu'on a les moyens
de faire ça? Ça veut dire qu'on
accepte de ne pas préparer
les citoyens et les citoyennes
de demain. Ça veut dire qu'on
accepte de continuer à ne pas
répondre aux attentes des
enfants. Tout ce que les enfants
veulent, c'est d'avoir quelqu'un
de bienveillant, de stable,
d'aimant, qui va les aider
à se développer.
- Mais c'est gigantesque.
Le virage prévention que vous
recommandez est gigantesque.
- Mais c'est du gros bon sens.
Ça peut avoir l'air gigantesque
parce qu'on s'est peut-être
habitué à : c'est du même que
ça marche. Non, c'est juste
du gros bon sens. Ce qu'on dit,
c'est qu'il y a des familles
qui vont vivre des difficultés
temporaires, prenez-en soin tout
de suite et ça va être réglé,
et on va éviter la récurrence
de la maltraitance, par exemple.
Les familles qui ont des grosses
difficultés, il y a des
programmes qui existent. Pouvez-
vous mettre ces programmes-là
en application de la meilleure
façon possible, selon les règles
de l'art, pour accompagner
ces familles? C'est ça
que ça veut dire.
- Avant que ça dégénère et avant
qu'on doive retirer un enfant
d'une famille. Il y a eu 118 000
signalements en 2019-2020.
C'est une augmentation de 12 %.
35 % d'augmentation depuis
2015-2016. Là, j'arrive à après
la prévention, à la DPJ, à la
boîte de la DPJ elle-même. Vous
dites que les intervenantes sont
surchargées. Comment on fait
pour régler ça?
- Elles sont surchargées et
elles sont aussi en souffrance,
elles nous l'ont dit. Parce
qu'elles sont surchargées,
parce que n'ont pas de soutien
clinique, parce qu'elles n'ont
pas de lieu, si elles vivent
des situations très difficiles,
pour être capables de ventiler
un peu. Donc, ce qu'il faut pour
les intervenantes, entre autres,
c'est mieux les former, mieux
les accompagner, mieux les
soutenir au niveau clinique.
Et c'est comme ça qu'on va
être capable de les retenir.
Plusieurs nous ont dit : "Moi,
je vais partir parce que j'ai
personne. Les plus expérimentés
n'ont pas le temps de
m'accompagner quand j'ai un cas
complexe. Mes gestionnaires sont
loin." Donc, c'est ce soutien
clinique. Et aussi, il faut
reconnaître que la pratique
en protection de la jeunesse,
la pratique avec les jeunes
en difficulté doit être reconnue
comme une pratique spécialisée
et valorisée comme telle.
- Donc, ça veut dire ajustement
de salaire, ça veut dire...
Est-ce que le ratio
intervenante-familles doit être
changé? Est-ce qu'on doit...
Est-ce qu'il manque
des intervenantes?
- Le ratio doit absolument
changer. Et ce qu'on dit, c'est
qu'au lieu d'avoir un chiffre
pour un chiffre, que ce soit 20,
22, 18, il faut que la charge
soit proportionnelle aux besoins
des familles. Il y a des
familles où c'est des cas les
plus complexes. On a affaire
à peut-être plusieurs enfants.
Alors, ça se peut pas qu'elle
ait le même nombre de cas qu'une
autre collègue à côté où il y a
moins de cette complexité-là
dans les familles. Alors,
il faut regarder à partir
des besoins. Qu'est-ce qu'on
doit donner comme services
aux familles? Comme temps
aux familles? Comme visite dans
les familles? Et c'est à partir
de ça qu'il faut construire pour
chaque intervenante. Combien
de cas, je m'excuse de parler
de cas, mais c'est leur langage,
combien de cas est-ce qu'on va
lui donner? Parce que quand
ils nous ont parlé, ils nous ont
parlé de fatigue de compassion.
Alors, qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec
cette fatigue de compassion?
Comment on la règle? Il faut
leur permettre d'exercer
selon les règles de l'art.
- Et leur donner par exemple
des adjointes administratives.
Vous avez dit ça en conférence
de presse, ça m'a frappé. J'ai
dit : ça c'est pas si compliqué,
mais il faut ouvrir... Mais ça,
c'est tout de l'argent,
vous êtes consciente de ça?
- Mais là-dessus,
le gouvernement a commencé,
quand on parle des adjointes
administratives. Parce qu'on
l'avait alerté déjà,
le ministère, dans les rapports
antérieurs et ils l'ont
commencé. Et ce qu'on leur dit :
poursuivez. Parce que c'est
quand même pas normal qu'une
intervenante passe 1h30 parce
qu'elle doit faire coordonner
des rendez-vous pour une
famille. C'est quelque chose que
quelqu'un d'autre peut faire
et libérer ce temps-là.
Donc, c'est possible
de continuer de le faire.
- OK point rapidement, vous
dites : nommer un commissaire ou
une commissaire à la protection
de la jeunesse. Qu'est-ce que ça
va changer?
- Commissaire au bien-être et au
droit de tous les enfants du
Québec. En ce moment, il y a
personne qui est le porte-voix
de cette collectivité d'enfants.
Il y a personne fait la
promotion des droits des
enfants. Et c'est pour ça qu'on
dit qu'il faut aussi adopter une
charte des droits des enfants.
Et ça, il y a d'autres provinces
canadiennes qui l'ont déjà fait
et on a vu que ça a porté fruit
d'avoir un commissaire au bien-
être et au droit des enfants.
Les enfants font plus appel à
eux. Ils se sentent accueillis.
- Très bien. Et puis, Régine
Laurent, on en a beaucoup parlé
depuis plusieurs semaines,
plusieurs mois même,
ce changement de loi que
vous préconisez, la loi
de la protection de la jeunesse,
pour encourager que
des placements deviennent
permanents, autrement dit. Pour
ne pas qu'il y a des va-et-vient
dans la famille biologique.
Expliquez-moi le changement
que vous voulez voir.
- Alors, ce qu'il faut toujours
voir en premier, c'est
l'obligation de donner
tous les services à la famille
biologique. Ça, il faut que
ce soit clair. Maintenant, une
fois qu'avec les délais prévus
dans la loi, on se rend compte
que ce ne sera pas possible
que l'enfant retourne dans
sa famille biologique, il faut
arrêter les essais-erreurs et la
DPJ doit aller devant un juge
et déclarer cet enfant-là apte
à l'adoption ou l'enfant est
sous tutelle. Ça peut être
dans la famille élargie.
Et on propose même qu'il y ait
une nouvelle forme d'adoption
où l'enfant n'est pas obligé
de couper les liens avec
sa famille biologique.
- Parce que ça existe ailleurs.
- Ça existe ailleurs. Par
exemple, chez les communautés
autochtones, c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'adoption coutumière.
L'enfance et qui sont ses père
et mère, mais l'autorité
parentale est transférée à
quelqu'un d'autre et l'enfant
sait qu'il est dans cette
stabilité-là, qu'il y a sept
adultes bienveillants qui va
être là tout le long de sa vie.
C'est ça dont l'enfant a besoin,
de stabilité, de permanence et
d'avoir une stabilité affective.
Il y a des jeunes qui nous l'ont
dit : "Moi, j'aurais été
contente, et ma famille
d'accueil voulait m'adopter.
Mais vous m'avez demandé...
Ça me demandait de renier
mes parents." C'est comme ça
que les jeunes le voit. Alors,
on comprend le déchirement.
Il y a moyen de faire autrement.
Et c'est une des propositions
qu'on fait.
- Très intéressant, cette
proposition-là d'adoption
simple. On va en reparler.
Madame Laurent, je boucle
la boucle quand même, tout ça
ne sera possible... tout ça
sera possible s'il y a un
investissement quand même assez
important, on va se le dire.
- Il y a un investissement,
mais il y a quelque chose aussi,
ça veut dire un changement
de culture. Et ça, ça prend
du temps. Ça prend beaucoup
de volonté, le changement
de culture. Alors, ça aussi,
c'est très important.
- Régine Laurent, présidente
de la commission spéciale sur
les droits des enfants et de la
protection de la jeunesse. On va
en reparler. 24/60 vous invite
ce soir, édition spéciale